here's how I ended up simplifying things
I'd love to see great testing ideas so
if you are particular to what you've
created post your solution to the forums
I'm starting off refactoring things a
little bit what I'm going to do is I'm
an add a function to get the location
content values this will be useful when
we actually try to use these tests for
some other things later on and there we
are a function that will return location
content values I'm also going to pull
the city name out so we can use that for
some validation steps later on and there
we are it's now inside of the function
and then we're just simply going to call
that function to get our location
content values and we can delete all of
those lines of code now all of these
columns as I said before are not very
important so we can delete them and we
can also know out the value in our query
the next thing I want to do is actually
fix this validation step we can do is we
can create a function that relies on the
fact that we can get the map and set
from our content values then we can
simply iterate through those then we can
see if the values that we use to create
the record actually pass the values in
the cursor that are returned now back to
our test so there's a lot of unnecessary
code here now all we have to do is call
validate cursor with our values and our
cursor alright so now we've converted
the first test we can do the same thing
with the second test as well first of
all let's do the same abstraction we did
before now of course one of these values
isn't going to be static so we have to
add that in so now we can say content
values equals get whether content values
with our all-important location row ID
remember our tables are linked and then
we can insert it into the database query
for it if the query is successful we can
just call validate cursor again on our
weather values with our weather cursor
so much less code and that's it our test
is vastly simplified and it will be
useful to us later on so now we can try
running this test again to see if it
still works after the refactoring and
there we are tests passed now I'd
probably be you
so for us to actually print out some
more data so we could see what was being
tested but this simplification to our
test is gonna help us as we move forward
we're not done with testing yet